my family name my bread on the
battlefield swinging pickaxes on the
back of a horse you know what I mean
that's where the McGregor name comes
from we come from the Scottish Highlands
well Warriors it's all I know it's all
we know so I'm gonna be doing it for a
long long time yet people walk away from
the sport it's not like your physical
body lets you down it's just a mental
fatigue of it all you know what I mean
Tyson said a quote that uh I was
interested in he said what customado say
to you now now that you're coming back
he said what took you so long and I
agree with that you know what I mean I'm
gonna keep going and that's it you'll
never get rid of me this game this game
is a Mayan this City Las Vegas is a mine
this world is a mine so I'm just
focusing on my own game focusing on my
own self I've come through a lot you
know what I mean it's been a tough
couple of months it's just a very into
the mental block of of the break
happening but I feel like you know I
feel great to be honest I feel very
confident I feel eager to get back and
I've got truer I'm proud of myself to
get through it I look forward to you
know inspiring the many people all
across the world that face you know
tough times in their life tough injuries
and you know I hope my story and my
journey can motivate them also and
that's that's a goal of mine too I love
the trail of it I love it all I love the
fight I love the business about it I
love everything about it people ask me
that all the time why am I here I'm you
know am I too accomplished every year
you know but
it's what I love to do it's all I do you
know I'm at a hungry lion I once was you
know maybe not it's certainly different
but I'm I'm I'm now the Fat Cat you know
what I mean I'm the Fat Cat pulling all
the strings around here and that's an
even more dangerous individual so you
know and I'm also you know couldn't wait
till I am hungry so you got to get in
there and improve all all the people uh
you know all my Delta's wrong and all my
support is correct you know I do a lot
of this for fans I have to I love to get
in and get in and show my appreciation
for the fans every time I sit in in an
interview it's oh why are you here you
have too much money you're too
successful you're doing it all blah blah
blah you know when the last fight I kind
of bought into that you know I was in
the press conference and a guy was
reading out
quote of mine from many years ago where
I was like talking about I can't wait
I'm gonna I'm gonna put my mother in a
mansion I'm gonna you know my
girlfriend's gonna have a car for it
every day of the week and you know I was
feeding into that wow I did all this I'm
where I am I'm grateful I'm proud of
where I am and what I've achieved but
there's a lot more left in me I'm still
very young I'm very fresh in the game
and I'm a dangerous man only 22 years of
age fresh fresh is anything I'm ready to
go so I'm gonna prove how dangerous I am
because trust me in the mindset I'm in
I'm really really dangerous Society
tells you growing up you should you
should fantasize about kicking a ball
and dream about that but it didn't
really interest me I tried to maybe
pretend that I was interested in it but
really kicking the ball straight into a
net is pretty cool but what happens if
someone runs up behind me and hits me
two shots into the Melt then I did so
cool so that was in my head as a young
kid I had a self-defense mind I was
aware where I come from and where I grew
up you had to be aware you had to be
able to defend yourself so that's that's
how I got into it Irish Motors will
support you no matter what you do my
father always jokes that I could be
doing anything and my mother would still
be my biggest fan so my father was
unaware of what the game was what the
sport was before me there was no Irish
man that had succeeded in the UFC there
was no one I could not look to my mother
and father and say look at this Irish
man look at his successful fighting
career because there was no one before
me so I was the first one I had to
convince them what I was going to do but
as far as my father was father was
concerned it was I was just fighting in
a cage and with no career path or no
nothing ahead of me so it was more Woody
but I convinced them and now here we are
there are many many young kids who are
seeing the pot now there are many many
parents of young kids who are seeing my
path and encouraging their kids into a
game of martial arts and whether the kid
you put your child into martial arts or
whatever it allows them to go and
Conquer whatever they want to whether
they want to conquer the fight game they
can whether they want to go and conquer
the business game or whatever
route they decide to take training from
martial arts will help help them so I am
happy that I have put martial arts in
the spotlight in my country and showing
it for what it is true dedication and
beautiful uh discipline it's just about
not translating it into the game you
can't be nice in this business that's
for sure no matter what you know what I
mean you've got to be rudeless in it
I've got to stay ruthless that's that's
what I've been saying you know in the
most ruthless business of all I am the
most ruthless and that's that's what it
is and that's where where I am yeah I'm
on a nice little path right now with
it's more it's not so much to the
opponents there is a bit of that with
the opponents of course it's more the
behind the scenes the business aspects
and things like that you know that's
kind of what's halted it a little bit
but like I said I'm on a great path now
we've got this Trilogy we've got big
things planned for after and I'm excited
about it it's hard to juggle it's hard
to go face to face I want to tear
through a man and then hold your your
son or your daughter and give them a
bottle you know and feed them and this
type of thing so
I've stayed away from that for for this
one and I've actually I feel I feel
great I've not I've not switched roles
almost I've stayed in the in in that
mode that I need to be in even if I
would say like rest days you know like
on a rest day when I would have rest day
around my family it's not really a rest
day I'm playing with the kids I'm busy
it's my rest days have been true rest
days so then when I go again for my next
round of work I'm energized I'm
refreshed and it's you know shown in the
in the practice room it's not even
enduring I'm just I'm embracing it my
frame is is light I'm a true lightweight
frame now I'm Zippy I'm fast I'm
powerful I have not only maintained
strength I've actually gone open in
strength and power the weight is on
point as it's ever been and I'm very
excited you know moons are fully
committed things are easy it's that
simple hard things become easy when you
commit yourself fully and that's what
I've done so I'm very excited to get in
and showcase myself at 155 pounds fully
focused I'll probably never retire from
the game to be honest I'll always be
I'll always I'll be competing for a long
long time yet it has certainly brought
out of frustration you know when you're
trying to get these events going you're
trying to get things moving and it's
just not happening it felt like I was
shelved almost you know I felt like if
I'd have been ran out a couple more
times that year not only with my skill
set my sharpness everything be in tune a
lot more we'd also be talking the goods
of 800 million dollars in revenue for
the company and you know it just it was
certainly out of frustration but it is
what it is the past is the past we're in
a great spot now I feel like I've got
what I needed to get off my chest and I
felt like it's it's been reciprocated
well and it's come back you know there's
the other side has come back as well so
I'm in a great spot and I'm excited to
come back and that's what that's what
we're at we're focusing on the positive
side of it and we're focusing on the
future wins and losses and all this it
means nothing to me if you're scheduled
to fight a man and you've gone through
build up and there's there's history and
all of this
fight is a fight and fights must take
place every fight is different
regardless of anything every fight
between every man is different and a
fighter to take place they must take
place you know I mean you can't Scurry
away and not get the fight scene that
you were supposed to fight that's my
opinion of it and you know I don't care
how many wins or how many losses you
have I mean it's nothing to me I thought
I fought unbeatened everything in in
different sports and all I would fight
anyone if you want to fight someone
you're supposed to fight them they
should happen so you know especially as
I get older in life I am you know I feel
it's our duty as human beings to give
back I think we've all got to give back
in this in this world and as I'm getting
older right I have so much admiration
for the coaches and the trainers and the
teachers because if you think about it
they dedicate they are it's all
volunteer work you know they dedicate
their time to help train the youth and
guide the youth I have so much
admiration for that you know growing up
I would never really think of like the
coaches or anything in that in that way
that these people are actually taking
time they've got their own families
they've got their own things but here
they are dedicating their time to help
coach and train the youth and give them
an outlet a much needed Outlet
especially in this day and age so I want
to go back and support that I'm going to
support people to support people you
know support support these these gyms
and these these places and that's that's
what my aim will be for this part of my
life
[Music]